right good okay well thank you very much
everybody and isn't it fantastic to be
here in stoke
and i've just i've just been to a a
brilliant ceramics company where uh i
they the job that they gave me to do was
to see if i could break uh the china and
uh and i i did i hit it out repeatedly
with a with a with a wooden mallet it
wouldn't break i i hit it harder and
harder it still wouldn't break and i can
tell you this this incredible company is
now doing better and better and uh it's
called churchill ceramics and what
they're doing is putting on jobs at an
extraordinary rate they've had 300 more
people their markets are expanding in
europe alone uh by 30 and they want more
people and i use this as an illustration
of what is happening here in stoke but
also what is happening in the country
because the the most extraordinary thing
about the way the country came back from
the covers pandemic was the strength of
the employment position people said uh
that uh that we would have employment
unemployment running at 12 to 40 percent
uh it's back down to i think what 3.8
uh rishi and that is the single most
important thing uh that we need to be
focusing on a strong jobs-led recovery
we're going to make sure that we use all
our ingenuity all our compassion uh
everything that we need to do to help
people through the difficult aftershocks
of kobe uh and and the the the
inflationary pressures that we're seeing
are particularly on the cost of energy
but what the queen speech will also do
is give us the legislative firepower to
deliver on uh tackling the underlying
issues the things that are driving up uh
prices particularly uh for energy uh for
uh for people's transport uh for for the
education that people need and that is
why i think the korean speech is is so
important
infrastructure
education technology those are the
things that we need to focus on
particularly cutting the cost of energy
making our streets safer
so that businesses have the confidence
to invest and to grow and that is how we
will put on
more jobs that is how we will improve
the skills of our population and that is
how we'll get the the the virtuous uh
cycle that we need uh to take the
country through so no lack of resource
and compassion now we're going to have
to be very very committed very very
radical very very forward thinking but
stick to the basics of our thinking
about getting people into high-wage
high-skill jobs i'm i'm encouraged by
some of the uh the the the things i'm
seeing here in stockholm encouraged by
the by the growth figures i just saw uh
this morning uh folks uh we're gonna get
through this it's going to take a lot of
focus but jobs jobs jobs is the answer
and that is how we will unite a level up
across the whole of the country and get
on with delivering on the mandate that
the people gave us uh two and a half
years ago thank you all very much